the gyro can experience but now now we
see this pop up again and so I'll tell
you what man the scariest thing is how
these social the social networks remove
like we talked abouts last year they
remove a certain point of view like this
biotech company they default on what is
authoritative and the authoritative
falls in one direction almost every
single time Falls left right yes so you
know I can't tell you how many how many
stories I've gone through where it's
like you know that Peter Navarro story
where Trump said to the journalist
you're a nasty nasty reporter and
everything yes
what you don't see was the full context
where the guy kept goading Trump for
like 10 15 minutes and then finally
Trump snaps at him and they take that
one soundbite and say look at Trump just
being a dick it's like well yes Trump's
got no filter and he gets mad but they
cut out the entire exchange where this
dude was poking and prodding and like
really just insulting the guy so this
guy Peter Navarro he's saying things
like why are you trying to give people
hope don't you think that offering up
false hope is is wrong and Trump's like
no I don't think so I think Laura Quinn
yeah
so you get a you get a guy that keeps
you know goading him and arguing with
them and that's what the point is making
earlier it's these people is for CNN and
whatever Network have realized hey we're
gonna get ratings but let me tell you
first of all that way of communicating
is [ __ ] terrible it's second only to
the terribleness that in those
late-night news shows where they have
three different people like with three
to the screen separated into three
chunks and this person on the right is
arguing with this person left the
moderator is trying to keep everybody in
order and everyone's talking over
everybody and everyone's looking for a
soundbite and everyone's looking to get
their shots in before the buzzer because
there's like a Bell coming right the
commercial runs it is the dumbest way to
really explore a complicated idea right
and second only to that is these [ __ ]
things where this the president stands
the podium and people yell things out
did someone called it to come flu yeah
someone called it to come flu do you do
not denounce that this racist word come
flu and Trump said who said it yeah I
don't know I heard I don't know you know
I loved when one of the journalists
asked Trump off the price of oil he goes
where's it at and the guy says oh I
don't know but I know where
the price of oil the reporter says I
don't know then why are you asking next
question yeah
these people are don't they don't know
there look I've sat in these rooms at
press conferences I have I have stood in
front of public officials as they
prepared an announcement and I know
exactly I've talked to these producers
I've talked to the journalists they're
like ask question what should I ask just
just ask anything so they they've I've
been thrown in front of people like ask
them something I'm like what am I
supposed to ask him ask him anything
make something up
because they want you get that screen
time so they can say it's theirs
well it's also someone like Jim Acosta
for example don't you think there's an
inclination when someone gets a certain
amount of attention to lean towards that
attention this is your base now these
are the people that are supporting you
and you find it with like online
commentators and where what's really
weird is one like a person used to be
left and then you see they get them
getting a little bit of love from the
right and they start like entering over
there and their comments and they get
more and more attention and then they
just jump ship and the inverse like
people who were leaning towards more
right wing talking points got attacked
for it and then immediately came out in
support of certain politicians yes yeah
yes you see people leaning towards what
gets them the most amount of love right
and for Jim Acosta like that it seems
like he gets a lot of love for attacking
this guy because he's talking for them
for the people at home actually I could
ask the president what the [ __ ] are you
doing this kind of get him Jim and this
is the it's it's and it's it's scary
when I go on reddit for instance and
they've basically purged 90% of any
pro-trump point of view really it's gone
man I I pull up I pull up reddit and
what do I get
it's it's it's all lefty commentary if
you go to like our slash politics which
has I think you know 5 to 6 million subs
they use left-wing activist websites as
new sources so it's not a place for real
political discussion it's a place to get
your biases confirmed this ain't the
same is true for the donald trump
subreddit which has been basically
purged you know they like they used to
have a real subreddit called the donald
and they know yeah they killed it they
killed it because they thought that it
was filled with trolls right they killed
it because they claimed
supporters were threatening cops I'm not
joking that's this that's the story does
that sound a little strange to you that
Trump supporters would be anti cop to me
sense so II that doesn't make any sense
that you would use that as an example
for an S to see a necessary move to ban
the entire subreddit it seems like so
it's not banned what is it it was
quarantined quarantine so you can no
longer you can no longer search for it
the only way to access it is to be
subscribed until I give your email
they've since abandoned that and created
a new website the Donald dot win you go
there you're gonna hear only good things
about the president and while there are
certainly things you'll just like any
rational person would disagree with I
think a healthy this course tries you
know you want you want to see the
counter points you want to see the
positive points you want to better
understand you know is there a real
reason why Donald Trump did something or
is he just an idiot and if you're only
getting one side of it your view of the
world is just total and it used to be
like the Wild West right it was pretty
wild until eighteen there's very little
moderating reddit is so incredibly easy
to manipulate and control at
ridiculously easy that you know I
remember and what year was maybe twenty
fifteen political operatives were
seeking ways to prop up politicians
manipulating reddit algorithms because
users have direct control of it I'll
just tell you it's ridiculously easy to
do like insanely easy they've since made
it more difficult but one person with
the hat with it with ten cell phones and
you could own the front page of Reddit
very very easily
that's crazy since then we've seen
accusations of and I think it's fair to
say you know in my experience I know
that this you know this tends to exist
the sock puppetry when someone runs
multiple accounts pairing to be
different people to create the
perception of consensus yes and that's
what they do that's really really common
super now I know a guy who is a
moderator it read it they told me this
one account had nine different people or
nine what one person had nine different
accounts yeah they were using to attack
this guy and you can can so the way
right it works for those I don't know is
you upvote and downvote something if it
has more up votes it moves up
if it has more down votes it does
Absolut disappears so if you create a
bunch of different accounts using proxy
servers or you know other IP
manipulation you can make sure your post
is always in front now was there a
concern that the Donalds
that the donald reddit site was being
manipulated that someone that they were
basically just using it early on yeah
yeah there was a so the donald post
would frequently hit the front page of
all so if you go to Reddit and you want
to see every subreddit that Donald was
always on top sometimes it was so active
that depends on who you ask
right or because people were
manipulating it one of the other I it's
that there's a good argument for both I
don't have the evidence to give you a
definitive answer I think it's fair to
say that Trump supporters will smash the
upload button make sure those posts
always fly to the top because they're
very enthusiastic very enthusiast it's
also possible that somebody had a bot
you know botnet that was you know yeah
yeah but one of the things that the
Donald got in trouble for I think was
they would they would do what's called a
sticky post so that means if you went
there
one post was always on top of their page
so the supporters knew top-voted
guaranteeing it would get a lot of
traction but we actually saw this is the
craziest thing the CEO of Reddit
manipulated in the database someone's
comment who was a trump supporter it's
actually this is like could you imagine
the CEO did this the editor he went into
the database the hard database for
someone's comment and changed what they
said what yeah he apologized for it
saying I got new I got angry
someone called him a pedo so he was like
oh yeah and he went in oh that's right
I remembered this he actually edited the
words to make that personal piece of
[ __ ] like anti-trump or something yeah
so I'll tell you what man look there's
there's there's a lot of arguments you
can make about policy and the right way
to solve these problems but I go on the
front I go I open read and I'm browsing
through it and I see these comments from
people that clearly do not understand
what's going out with these protests
that people want the economy to reopen
and I try and talk to my friends about
it and it seems like they're trapped
because I think you know it's like you
were mentioning how people drift towards
what gets them the most love but now
it's not just famous people it's not
just people on social media it's
everybody who does that and they don't
want that worldview bro
[Applause]